hey guys sorry I have not been around
for a little while this is because this
isn't a regular thing by the way some
people said that I've missed several
weeks of logging ex vlog isn't like ox
log it's not gonna be a regular
occurrence it's just wherever I feel
like I haven't been around for long
enough or something interesting to
happen in addition I've also not been
terribly well since moving here
apparently I've been exposed to various
pathogens from all parts of the UK that
I've never seen before so my body just
died for the past couple of months and
I've just you know been a bit busy
so absolutely tonnes has happened to me
since I last talked to you I guess the
first thing was the fact that my best
friend John who some of you might
remember from my bawling video if you
haven't seen that by the way go and
check out I'm really proud of that video
it took me to see the NFL play in
Wembley Stadium in London which was the
San Francisco 49ers versus the
Jacksonville Jaguars and we've both sort
of recently got into American football a
little bit and we wanted to see it live
I started supporting the 49ers so it was
it was a birthday present to me and it
was amazing although really not what I'm
used to I mean I'm a kid from the West
country I come from a small town before
that a village so I am used to small
numbers of people I don't deal well in
large crowds so this is not what I'm
used to
I'm not used to being in a stadium with
84,000 people it was just so great
thank you John I know you're watching
before the game I also stopped off in
Oxford on the way to London and met up
with your other Ox loggers now if you
are following youtube-dot-com
forward-slash
ox log you will probably have known
about this because they have fewer than
posted footage in their vlogs basically
we just met up and actually met each
other for the first time and and had
lunch and it was really really nice
they're a bunch of really really cool
guys if you're not following the channel
yet please do a little after that on
Halloween me my girlfriend Jenny went to
a Halloween dress-up party as a film
noir couple to do this we basically went
in black and white and had an
accompanying pumpkin she took forever to
do but I'm really proud I probably
mentioned this other than the vampires
that I was so proud of how it turned out
and most recently outside of Exeter I
went back to Oxford to go to some Peters
MCR guest night when my friend Ryan who
some of you may remember from the access
videos that we did invited me back along
with some of my friends to take part in
what's basically like a fan
dinner and I had this amazing lend it
was one the nicest meals ever although I
had drunk for a while and it hit me
rather hard pack you next isn't all work
I mentioned in my last vlog that I'm
active in the a cappella Society
specifically I'm in the Harmonix group
and madrigals group I wanted to part in
the remembrance service on the 11th of
November in Exeter Cathedral which was
incredible it's a if you've ever visited
x2 you will know how beautiful the
building isn't it's this huge Cathedral
and actually singing it was something
which I never thought would have
happened when I first came here I also
filmed a gig done by the sweet-nothings
which is the university's all-female a
cappella group at the old firehouse pub
they actually had their own YouTube
channel which has some of the set which
I recorded on it but here's a brief
snippet
however a lot of my time here has been
working or work-related so as part of
the PhD course here they're very keen
for you to progress yourself and to not
diverge but - I guess diversify your
skills so they encourage you the very
force you to take over a hundred hours
of taught assessed courses over the
course of your PhD so for me if you've
been following me on Twitter you'll know
that I'm taking a course on string
theory and I'm also doing some
statistics modules and I'm gonna be
doing some more of these modules next
time in addition I've been teaching
myself to program in Python and trying
to construct a very basic climate model
which has been going slowly slowly but
surely I like to think my my planet now
survives for a couple of days before it
explodes
which is nice eventually I'm going to
have got a fully working client model
and I've actually like to do a video and
how you construct the earth because it's
really interesting to me how you with a
computer program have the freedom to
just create a world and you include the
physical mechanisms that you wanted to
so for example the planet I'm working
with at the moment it has oceans which
move according to the navier-stokes
equations and and the motion of the
planet it has a Sun which passes
overhead and so you get day and night
cycles and it has a different amount of
sunlight coming in at different
latitudes so the equator receives more
sunlight at midday than the poles do but
there's so much I'm not including it
doesn't have an atmosphere for example I
mean that's quite a big thing at the
moment I'm just rying to get the gross
structure down then gonna add bit by bit
by bit I think it could make quite an
interesting video let me know if you'd
be interested in that in fact I asked on
Twitter what people knew about the
stratosphere now the stratosphere is
what I'm researching at the moment
specifically I'm researching how it
couples to the troposphere so the middle
atmosphere and the lower atmosphere
prospectively people apparently don't
know very much about it
which I guess is to be expected because
really if you want to understand what's
going on you need to use physics you
need to use things other than I guess
the skills you would use when you were
taught the stuff by the atmosphere
basically GCC or a-level geography so
something I'd actually really like to do
a kind of atmosphere 101 kind of video
introducing you to the basic stuff about
the atmosphere and its structure what's
going on above our heads at all times
that's the incredible thing you look up
and that's that's what I'm studying I
don't have to like abstract it like I
did when I was doing my undergraduate in
physics it's kind of there let me know
if you'd be interested in that because
the atmosphere is not a static boring
place there's a little tons of stuff
going on I'm biased I'm researching it
but you know let me know if you be
interested I think that's actually it a
lot of the work which I've actually been
doing the papers which I've been reading
I can't condense down right now because
in order to make a meaningful video
about it I need to study the whole
picture hopefully that's something I'm
going to do in the future
and talk a little bit about my research
to do with the interaction of the middle
atmosphere and a lower atmosphere and
why it's relevant and why it's
interesting in addition I'm definitely
gonna do a quick string theory video
bear in mind that I've only been doing
10 lectures on this I'm not an expert in
string theory by any measure so that's
going to be a primer like it like a very
brief introduction to but I'm looking
forward to doing so yeah I think that's
it let me know in the comments what
video you like me to or videos you'd
like me to do and others it around that
I'd literally just remembered right now
it's getting close to Christmas there's
less no Christmas well if you're
watching this the day that I upload it
in the future sorry you probably missed
Christmas bass bass con t-shirt by the
way in case you're frustrated or not
going oh it's this one again